billionaire richard branson has earned
his
astronauts wings it's a complete
experience
the flight went off without a hitch the
space plane
unity was lifted skyward attached to a
double fuselage mothership
called eve after branson's mother
release release release at high altitude
unity separated from eve then fired its
powerful rockets
blasting branson three virgin galactic
executives
and a pair of pilots to a height of 88
kilometers above
earth that is not exactly outer space
the international scientific body that
decides such things says
space begins at 100 kilometers but that
hardly seemed to matter
as the passengers and crew enjoyed the
incredible views of the earth below
with the darkness of space above
they also experienced several minutes of
microgravity allowing them to float
nearly weightlessly the 70-year-old
british entrepreneur won the billionaire
space race beating
amazon's jeff bezos and spacex founder
elon musk
to the heavens bezos plans to lift off
in his blue
origin space company's rocket on july
20th
musk's plans for space travel haven't
been announced
after maneuvering for re-entry unity
glided to a flawless landing at the
virgin galactic spaceport
in a remote section of the new mexico
desert
as onlookers cheered the entire flight
lasted
about an hour back on earth branson held
a news conference
honestly nothing could prepare you for
uh the view of earth
from space i mean the whole thing
was just magical then it was time to
celebrate
branson's plan is to make space tourism
possible for earthlings
following today's successful flight
there will be several more tests of
branson's spacecraft
the goal is to send tourists into space
beginning next year the price tag two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars each
rob reynolds al jazeera in sierra county
new mexico